thank you so much for being here it's a
pleasure for us to be here I'll properly
introduce the guests in just a second
but the number of people here is not
just testament to the power of this
organization but also the interest in
this subject I suspect if I had two
years ago suggested that we might have a
conversation about cybersecurity we
would have been lucky to have filled a
phone box I'm suggesting that you still
know what a phone box is by the way but
now it's suddenly think wanna cry and
the impact that had on businesses around
the world and the impact it had on more
than 20 NHS trusts think as we will be
doing in just a second about the United
States election and the evidence that
emerged that the Russians were in fact
responsible for the hack of Hillary
Clinton's emails the evidence that's
emerged since terms the attack on
president McCoy as he wasn't at the time
happened but clearly the McCrone
campaign what has happened in the German
elections on what I am almost certain
has been happening here and will happen
here again and then let's just do a
little quiz who here in their personal
life if you could put your hand up has
found an email hacked or received a
hacked email or had a bank account
hacked you hear well we're all very much
personally interested in cybersecurity
so just to remind you the title of
tonight's event warfare the new rules
the cyber threat to states businesses
and all of us and we will attempt first
of all as the panel here to touch on all
three of those things and then to open
up to questions right let's reintroduce
your panel to you and we'll hear from
them one by one as well before we open
up to general discussion on my left jeh
Johnson Secretary of Homeland Security
from 2013 to 2017 under President Obama
a man who had a whole series of roles as
a leading lawyer in advising the US
government in advising the US military
on the legal framework within which they
operate but as head of Homeland Security
was responsible not just for
counterterrorism and borders Girja
nuclear threats of biological threats
and natural disasters all the rest but
of course for our subject tonight which
is cybersecurity we'll hear from him in
just a second Angela Sasser is next to
me as well professor of human centered
technology in the department of computer
science at University College London
which means as she will explain in a
second that she has been thinking longer
and harder about cybersecurity than
probably the combined ages of all the
people in these in this rooms forgive me
I'm not seriously your old Angela but
it's just that she has been thinking
about this long before most people in
this room knew what cybersecurity was
and has many insights to give and then
finally Jamie Bartlett now many of you
watch that excellent BBC two series
secrets of Silicon Valley will recognize
him if you've not seen it is it do you
have to know is it still on the BBC but
somebody will have ripped it off but
Jamie did that series but is known
particularly in this context for a book
called the darknet inside the digital
world and you'll see another of his
books outside radicals outside is
changing the world as well needless to
say he is an expert on this subject Jane
let us begin with you when we I
mentioned right at the beginning that
you're had a crucial role in not just
identifying in private but going public
with the information that was shocking
to many people at the time that Hillary
Clinton's emails and the DNC's emails
had been cracked and hacked by the
Russians how shocked were you or how
much was this something that you'd spent
many years thinking this will happen
soon first of all it's great to be here
this is a really really impressive
audience on a Monday night at the dinner
hour um Wow
I should apologize I'm getting over a
case of Bell's palsy I've had it now for
almost four weeks I didn't know what
Bell's palsy was a month ago but I
didn't have a stroke I didn't go to the
dentist I feel fine it doesn't matter
unless I try to smile or laughs yes so
emblematic of this I got a small story
to tell when I was Secretary of Homeland
Security in the United States I
testified before our Congress 26 times
in three years
wonderful experience they're like the
shareholders they want to hear from you
the testimony I gave that got the most
press attention was as a private citizen
this past June when I was asked to
testify before the House Intelligence
Committee about Russian hacking into
last year's US election I testified and
immediately after I testified the number
of people who recognized me went up
dramatically on the street on the train
in the New York City Subway everywhere
and the day after I testified Nick I was
on the Acela train the high-speed rail
from Washington to New York going back
home the lady next to me recognizes me
that two other people on the other end
of the car recognized me and I go to the
cafe car to get a bite to eat I'm in
this long line and there's this lady too
in front of me and she looks at me and
she's pulling out her iPhone she's
killing up the camera features okay she
wants a selfie fine
and as Nick mentioned I was Barack
Obama's Secretary of Homeland Security
she said to me sir I'm from the United
Kingdom my son back in the United
Kingdom greatly admires you and admired
all the wonderful work you did in office
I was so touched and flattered capping
off this week and she asked me may I
please have a selfie and I said but of
course so he took the picture she turned
around and looked at me she said thank
you mr. president
so that kind of deflated my balloon I
love the idea that she thought of the
president's got they you know the Amtrak
he's waiting for cheese and crackers
right so to answer your question Nick
when the Director of National
Intelligence and I issued that statement
on Friday October 7th 2016 we thought I
thought it was an unprecedented
statement to accuse a superpower of
interfering in our ongoing election that
this was going to be big news full
banner above the fold New York Times
Washington Post it happened however to
have been the same day as the release of
the now infamous Access Hollywood video
which came out an hour later so can I
interrupt for 30 seconds I was injured
by your choice of words it happened to
be the same day as you will know they'll
be plenty of people who believe that
that was released to distract or is that
just a wild conspiracy theory I think in
reality stuff doesn't always happen that
neatly and that quickly okay on with
your stories but you know so the press
was totally distracted by sex you know
lust and greed and went off to the other
end of the pasture to recover it was the
name forgive me because everyone people
different this is Trump talking about
griping women never to a TV host this is
the 11 year old video of Donald Trump on
this TV show saying some really kind of
x-rated things that had been long been
buried and it managed to surface right
in the middle of the campaign on the
same day we issued this statement and so
it wasn't until December really after
the election that the mainstream press
kind of woke up and said wow the
Russians interfered in our election and
I you know my reaction was yeah we told
you that two months ago and we can get
into the details of the thinking that
went into it very final brief thoughts
on that before I bring in Angela
opening thought how seriously should
that have been taken in that stage very
and and in other words I don't mean just
in in relation to that election you had
the leader of a foreign country a
superpower that many people consider our
adversary attempting to put his thumb on
the scale to affect the outcome of our
election and elect a certain person over
another person very seriously we'll come
back to the more detail on that in a
second and so let me bring you in when I
was looking at a little bit of what you
did and I talked about the expertise you
had in a sense we've heard there about
the threat to the state we want to move
on to talk about businesses and users as
well and you wrote what in the area of
expertise here is a rather famous paper
users are not the enemy what was the
thinking about that paper and what does
it tell you all the years are now about
the extent of what we're calling tonight
the warfare well at the end of the day
organizations and society and government
is made up of individuals and so it's
it's the extent to which we can look
after ourselves our interest our
security and our privacy and what I was
pointing out in that paper was that
employees really couldn't cope that the
the technology and procedures they they
were given by the company to to keep
access to systems secure they just
couldn't use you know because nobody can
have between 16 and 64 different
passwords 8 plus characters long you
know don't blame the users and the
relevance for tonight is that it's
almost are you saying it's almost a
false distinction to think of cyber
attacks on the state on businesses on on
users because it's always on users they
might reach this day that way it might
reach the business yes so so but my view
is the Internet now it's the fifth
utility and I think what you should have
to do to use it securely shouldn't
really be that much more than you know I
don't have to test my water every
morning to make sure it's safe
right in the sinus they don't stick a
fork in the socket the electricity it's
fine
you know I saw stripes start messing
around with something the qualified the
idea that I have to do some sort of
multiple digit password and then change
every month so bad that's different from
the one I did the other day and the app
you know and then you know I bet lots of
people here are getting bit fed up with
all the updates that constantly supposed
for their for their things that gives us
a thought of to be sort of digesting and
then we'll explore each of these in term
and Jamie I mentioned in particular of
this book that you wrote about the dark
web the unregulated web in other words
does that raise another issue for us
that for all we might sit here and say
you know the Internet is another utility
and we can tell Google what to do with
the banks and so on there's a whole
other bit out there which won't be
regulated at all yes I think that's
right and I think it's but it's also
built on the idea that it can't be
regulated I've been the whole philosophy
of it is that it's beyond the control of
nation-states it's beyond the control of
governments and this is the problem I
think this is what's happened in the
last five to ten years the
democratization of the various tools of
cybercrime the barriers to entry have
lowered greatly you don't any longer
have to be a skillful computer
programmer to be a cyber criminal it is
exceptionally easy you can go on the
darknet I'm not suggesting you do this
at home ladies gentlemen oh go download
all sorts of plug-in software or hire
somebody to hack into things for you and
I think this is a massive problem
because for most people their experience
of cybercrime is not Russians hacking
into things or big businesses losing
stuff
it's low-level stuff it's I it's
identification being stolen credit card
fraud bullying and harassment on social
media and my worry is the police cannot
deal with this we have a massive
enforcement crisis the police are
overwhelmed and what I greatly fear is a
loss of trust among ordinary people in
the ability of the police to do their
job online and and and and when that
happens what you get is digital
vigilantism
which is what's already happening well
we'll come back and we'll explore that
in just a second so let's pick up with J
then on the state first of all you've
told us how serious that was J gives us
into the wider scale should we assume
that Russia is trying to interfere with
every election in every western state
should we assume that is not just Russia
it's North Korea is it the Chinese as
well what is the scale of this we should
assume that particularly after last
year's experience a lot of actors the
nation-state actors criminals activists
are gonna try to do much of the same
thing and when we talk about
cybersecurity you can talk about it
limited to the state but it does affect
businesses and all the rest of us my
assessment is that it's going to get way
worse before it gets better
and those on offense right now have the
upper hand and those of us on defense
particularly in government struggle to
keep up those on offense are
increasingly creative tenacious
aggressive and those of us on defense
it's like trying to catch raindrops some
days and we've got to we've got a long
way to go before we turn the corner and
in the United States and I suspect here
in the United Kingdom to it there needs
to be a national conversation and making
this a national imperative with a
national spokesman to lead the charge on
behalf of all three constituencies the
state businesses and private citizenry
and investments in technology raising
awareness of general members of the
public people who use systems we've got
a we've got a long way to go with the
focus there in that announcement is
maybe all of the above but is the focus
therefore principally on the state's
response in other words in this country
I mean yours obviously will be the
department security FBI and elsewhere
but in this country might be here both
mi5 and mi6 and also the guys at GCHQ is
the focus on that for dealing with it or
is there no point in a sense in the
state
if the individual business well there
there are three components to a state
response one is the law enforcement
response which in our country is the FBI
and the Secret Service and a few other
agencies too is the response to the
nation-state actor in the nature of a
retaliatory action or some form of
response nation to nation which could
include something of an offensive
character and in my judgment as the
former general counsel of the Defense
Department need not be a response in
kind so crudely we'd have to disrupt
that I'm gonna be using vertical MERS
for elections in Russia and China
showing and we don't have to interrupt
their elections we don't have to do like
for like you don't have to do so like it
responsive it isn't as long as it is as
long as it is proportionate consists I
believe you should apply traditional law
of war principles these type of things
as long as it is proportionate necessary
and limits collateral damage but not
much in other words be an economic
talking in Russian it could take various
forms and then the third you'll
carefully don't tell okay let me let me
know try and push you on the specifics
but is your instinct in sanctions for
example against the Russians tend to
focus on individuals it's about
punishing those people in the Putin
circle who've got money in the West
particularly that is root is your
instinct that it's around that it's
around individual turns around the
economies a whole law sanctioning
individuals does seem to bother them it
does seem to matter and I'll say that
with respect to both the Russians and
other nation-state actors it seems to
matter that could be a component of it
but not not the only component my view
is that a response to a cyberattack
should include some element of something
some element that is cyber related that
has the effect of undermining the
enemy's ability to do it again or
unmanned unmasking the enemy's ability
to do it again and in the third
government response which is what
homeland security was focused on is
helping the victim patch the
vulnerability so I used to say Jim Comey
was the cop
I was the fireman helping the actor
patch the vulnerability identify the
vulnerability root to actor out of the
system and try to prevent it from
happening again I want to come home to
in a second with you two other attacks
because we particularly focused on
Elections but of course there's what
terrorist organizations are doing
there's the threat to country's
infrastructure and so but before I do
maybe I can bring in Andrew and Jamie
there's an interesting dilemma and I
suspect this applies to businesses as
well as to government and state actors
take the offensive response if you
expose what has happened to you and you
try and have an incentive for them not
to do it again the danger there's two
dangers one they realize what they've
done and they might not quite know you
give away valuable information and the
second of all a little bit like the dart
web response is okay you put them off
for a week a month a year but then they
get cleverer than you and they do it in
a place that you're not able to respond
yes and I think that is precisely what
has been happening in the early 90s the
US government had quite a big crackdown
on various forms of encryption very
nervous about military-grade encryption
being available to the public and it
became known as the crypto Wars and sort
of battle over the right to have
encryption and in the end the FBI lost
that battle but what it sparked off was
an amazing flurry of activity whereby
all sorts of activists were building
amazing open-source freely available
encryption which is still being used
today by various yes activists and
journalists but also all sorts of
criminals and I think we've seen exactly
the same thing after the Edward Snowden
revelations on the darknet but also
beyond there is amazingly exciting
developments in how to evade
censorship how to evade detection and I
firmly believe actually that we are
moving into an era where censorship of
the Internet is simply impossible
there will be no state no government
intervention nothing that can be done to
fully remove information from the
internet and I don't really know how we
deal with that but does it where if they
called you in and they what you were
advising its state actor but the sounds
of you'd say you know be a little wary
about this offensive reaction because
they'll beat you to it you know they'll
beat you in a year or they'll be you and
I would I would I mean I understand the
need to respond but I'd be very nervous
about the the counter response and so I
actually think it's we you know we
talked an awful lot about that we have
now a digital economy and a digital
society and I think the digital digital
citizenship hasn't really kept up with
us so so the kind of things I actually
worry about is how easy it is you know
if we look at for instance the Assyrian
Skype attack you know of basically fake
news you know through to create a panic
just before people are not familiar with
the Syrian sculpture so so this is
social engineering to get to get people
to reveal sensitive information because
I think they're talking to somebody who
is a friend you know Hobart who is
actually a foe and then using you know
this information can be used in various
ways but so for instance if you you know
if you cause a stock market panic if you
get people to start panic buying or
start to run on a bank you know that can
really seriously you know you damaging a
country's economy is a way of attacking
it and I think as individual citizens at
the moment we haven't really had the
conversation and the education to learn
of how we actually should react and
should deal with in a situation when
something has come up that we don't
become effectively a pawn in the you
know in this attacking scheme and I
think we really this is not part of the
national conversation at the moment and
it needs to be well let's come back to
that detail about how we do in tuesday's
just sort of finish off just the
introduction give me there's an email
going around the United States from jeh
Johnson
chief of homeland secure
you have five million dollars in a bank
account in Nigeria you can claim it you
need to claim it before next Tuesday so
we go to revelations day he is in fact
the President of the United States and
also worth five million dollars which is
great I'm gonna be a very very nice job
now what else do you want me to ask unit
vigor ability to move on GJ is as a you
focused on as it were particularly
Russians and the attack on elections
let's broaden it out do you also believe
that there is a sustained attempt to
attack both physical infrastructure
electricity supplies and so on and also
the as it were the infrastructure of the
Internet our ability at number two may
be related of course so that cities are
shut down or large parts of cities or
parts of the economic infrastructure in
them I believe that there are actors who
are most likely investigating the
capability and the possibility of doing
that I would not put that beyond the
comprehension of people out there and
you deliberately saying actors rather
than States or do you mean in the actors
and the board as I said actors in the
broadest possible sense and the broadest
possible sense so will tend anything and
then just a final thought I look before
as I say we pursue some the thoughts
that have been raised by the other two
people who I think will be fascinated by
the thought that you know that there can
be a proportionate reaction as you put
it in the way that there would be with
the military another response of course
would be to have a kind of Geneva
Convention cyber Geneva Convention which
is to put it rather crudely don't do it
to us or we'll do it to you let's just
agree what we're not going to do at all
practical interesting example in
September 2015 right after the hack of
the US Office of Personnel Management
were a lot of very sensitive background
check information was stolen we never
the US government never formally
attributed it to any one nation state
but the Chinese came to town it was
before President Xi's visit they were
very anxious to defuse that whole
controversy and we took the opportunity
to get the Chinese government to agree
to one of the international cyber norms
that a nation-state shall not attack
commercial enterprise for commercial
gain I'm paraphrasing but that was
basically it and they signed up to it
and when President Xi came for the UN
General Assembly in September 2015 he
made the pledge he came out of his own
mouth and that's something we negotiated
the general assessments including of
cyber security firms in the private
sector is that in so far as what we can
see that level of activity by the
Chinese has has de been dialed down
insofar as what we can see Jill Jill I
was going to say isn't it rather like an
11th commandment thou shalt not be so
now there are opportunities yeah they
may just be better at it there are
opportunities to make deals at the
bargaining table when the other side
perceives it to be in his interest as
well as one country we didn't mention I
mentioned and they seem to be broadly
was that the Russians going after
democracy the Chinese are interested in
business the North Koreans are
interested anything they can do we
didn't mention the Iranians and the
revelation here was that the hack on the
parliamentary email system walls or the
claim was I should say the revelations
no been confirmed it was a claim a
newspaper claim was that that was the
Iranians again surprising no each nation
state no each nation state has its own
character and style in terms of its
cyber capabilities its offensive cyber
capabilities and I would put the
Iranians not in the class with the US or
the
Chinese or the UK or the Israelis but
they're in the top I'd say they're in
the top 15 interesting quickly asked and
to what extent do you think that
governments should be responsible to
make sure their own citizens aren't
engaging in aggressive international
cyber warfare because one of the claims
is that actually Russia and China turn a
blind eye to some of the hacking groups
that operate on their soil
I think nation-states use cutouts in
other words you know if you ever watch
Mission Impossible if your corner
captured the Secretary will disavow
knowledge of your actions
yes nation-states tend to use cutouts
they tend to use actors homes or
arms-length
yeah and so it's not so much permitting
them but directing them to do something
that they then have deniability over it
was put to me by somebody in secures in
this country in a slightly different way
I just wonder if you share this view
before I bring in Jane and Jamie and
Angeles more which is that it was there
henry ii firm on on that in other words
president putin in effect says who will
rid me of this troublesome priest
whether that is Scotland from the United
Kingdom or the UK out of the European
Union or Donald Trump to be president
he's not stupid enough to sit there and
go you you do that but the word goes out
a lot of actors some of them state some
of them business some of them personal
know what it is that he's wanted does
that sound like a plausible description
yeah I'm not with that
I said take you places yeah what again
that's fine well let's let's just
explore a little bit more with Jamie and
bring the other two to comment on it and
then finally with UNG limousine so you
were beginning to describe and I think
people will be interested here that part
of what you said about the doll web was
exciting you didn't just say would you
easily could it on any or book does full
of pedophiles and criminals and you know
other bad actors
you said exciting just explore that for
could you well take for example the
cryptocurrency Bitcoin which actually
has amazing applications for payment
systems and the underlying technology of
Bitcoin is known as blockchain it's a
sort of decentralized ledger and
companies are pouring millions and
millions of dollars into working out how
they can develop these very very
interesting ways of storing information
that are impossible to censor or remove
but they're decentralized and that is
exciting I mean a lot of businesses see
the excitement of that and a lot of the
technology is really important to
understand that a lot of the technology
like that was developed by a group of
sort of radical libertarians who did not
like the nation-state who wanted to
build this stuff to upset governments
and will carve out a new face of freedom
they didn't build it for terrorists and
pedophiles they built it for journalists
and activists but inevitably it's kind
of both of those extreme groups that
tend to use it let's take one specific
because there'll be quite a lot of
people who have expertise in the
audience but forgive me I suspect quite
a lot who don't like me are interested
take blockchain I was in Silicon Valley
a little while after you did this and
kept being told of thick so I'm gonna
blockchain the way that journalists do
you blockchain mmm she gone to Google
that's Blocher course a course explains
me why BOC Dame is significant as I now
realize it is well the idea is that it's
a way that you can have immutable
records which are simultaneously shared
amongst lots of different people that
cannot be deleted or edited by any of
them but everybody can have the same
record and add to those records so it's
like it's a way of creating what they
call it an immutable decentralized
spreadsheet so let's say for example in
parts of the developing world there's
very little legal framework for proof of
ownership but if you could somehow
manage to record Land Registry data on a
blockchain it could not later be deleted
or chained
used by a government that decided they
wanted to take that land off you
so this is fat you know this is
potentially very very exciting bitcoin
is the most famous version of it and one
of the reasons that is so popular is
because it allows for instantanium near
instantaneous but semi-anonymous
transactions payments anywhere around
the world in a way that is extremely
secure so this is this yes an originally
curious way the dark web may turn out to
be a route to greater cybersecurity yes
or no yes i mean if everybody used the
tor browser for example which is a which
is a way of accessing the dark web you
would have a much greater level of
personal privacy to grow more here so
far which they which the US State
Department in fact for a long time has
funded because they see the value of it
for the spread of democracy and freedom
in the world I mean you won't find
people that are more obsessed with
internet security than a group of
hackers or drug dealers or others
operating on the dark now there is a lot
you can learn from there yeah and and is
it also just a last thought before I
bring the other two in easy it also
something that could mean in your series
your TV series is particularly about the
power of the giants of signals that can
rally were the apples or the Facebook's
or the Google's of way of undermining
their power for a lot of the activists
involved in this blockchain technology
and yes now it's being picked up by all
these businesses but a quarry is a
lyrical libertarian vision a lot of them
do detest the big centralized you know
Facebook's of this world with their big
servers that can be controlled and
manipulated by the people that owned the
data this is a rebellion against all of
that and I do think it's going to get
more popular because I think we're
seeing a bit of a tech backlash but can
I just say this one thing Edward Snowden
revelations are so important and not
necessarily for the reasons that people
think I think that Edward Snowden gave
people the impression that law
enforcement
omnipotent they can see everything they
can collect everything there's nothing
they can't do but the truth is with some
of this technology their job is really
getting harder this is why I was worried
is why I said at the beginning I'm very
worried about people's confidence in the
authorities because they simultaneously
think they capture everything we do
while they're not able to prosecute
crime agree with that I can tell you up
close and personal I agree with that
would you used when Edward Snowden's
revelations came in I or any of or any
of them repeatable well I wasn't no no
and in Jamie is absolutely right that
when when the Snowden revelations first
came out I thought our government did a
good job of declassifying enough about
those two programs so that the public
could understand what just got disclosed
but then it got away from us to the
point where there was so much
misinformation out there that the public
at large thinks that we surveil
everything we know everything with
encryption now it is much harder to
track crime it is much harder to track
potential terrorists plotting very often
in intelligence briefing at the end will
be caveated with and i can't know
everything because of the crips and in
fact factor anjali wants coming so it's
i think it's very clear that the Snowden
revelations raised awareness and that a
lot more ordinary citizens and consumers
got interested in using encryption but
the the studies that we've done actually
showed that over eighty percent of them
then give up very quickly because it's
so the tor browser is a great step
forward but most of most people still
don't use secure chat they don't encrypt
their email and they don't use the tor
browser because it they're finally just
too difficult it's and it's not just
that it's difficult in terms of
usability is we have a bootstrapping
problem right if
you you use email and chat because you
want to communicate with other people
and if they don't use the same secure
tool that you use then that becomes
really a big problem and that's at the
moment why why it gets sort of stuck and
it's not true but sorry but but I mean I
think the the maybe the bigger bit of
this is that a lot of the tech companies
started introducing default encryption
to all of their services as a result so
even just using whatsapp is more of a
pain for the authorities or signal or
some of the telegram some of the other
apps that have come out since the
Snowden revelations which you're right
are all about easy available use rather
than just wanna take us back to cyber
warfare just make sure that we stick to
you know our focus tonight when you hear
Jamie describe what's happening on the
dark web what does that tell you about
whether the job of people are you
advising people on cybersecurity where
the businesses or individuals that
getting harder as a result of them it is
but I don't think it necessarily needs
to be and we're seeing some green shoots
so I completely share Jim Jamie's
worried about that citizens might lose
trust in law enforcement but one of the
other ways we could you know another way
of looking at it is if we get the
service providers and law enforcement
and and consumers together and have a
conversation about this I actually think
that we're now very slowly see service
providers stepping up to taking more
responsibility in this space because if
you for instance have widespread fraud
on certain internet platforms on the
electronic markets and so on it's the
service providers themselves if they're
put there actually if they invest in it
put their mind in it and work with their
customers and with law enforcement they
can actually spot a lot of those this
for a lot of that that fraud and stop it
from happening and they can give I mean
if you go on somewhere like Gumtree for
instance you can see that they place
certain ads and when you click on them
they say okay we place this ad here to
show you what a fraud unit looks looks
like right and and that and and or you
go to the dating sites most of the
providers now they are trying to weed
out the
you know the ones that basically start
50 conversation simultaneously can just
joy and wheedle money out of individuals
and so on the sort of cybersecurity
we've so far talked about in a census
that is state to state as we've talked
about clearly economic injures if we
just ask the audience in terms of the
data that people can get well we haven't
really focused on yet is information in
other words using that as a blackmail
tool so not information in order to
access my bank account but information
purely because I then know something
about you or your business
the you will pay me not to reveal is
that a common nail it is but actually
there's even a slightly more mundane
version of it so we have seen that that
some nation states effectively use
several use battalions directed by
psychologists to collect informations
about certain people of interest and
certainly we're pretty sure that anybody
who works in cyber security is a person
of interest it's cut when you say
nations are doing it unlike je you've
got no constraints of former being a
former a head of Homeland Security says
can we name a couple of names which
countries are doing it I'd rather not
but could so that basically that you
know they actually they do you know they
don't necessarily linear between the
individual and the company and so if
they're interested in a particular
company any individual working there is
of interest and sometimes it might not
even be black Miley it may simply be
that at some point they go and just
reveal you know look this is everything
we have about you and to just basically
get people to get out of the out of the
sector you know just to freak them out
of freak this is the first time I'm
hearing it and J I'm sure it's not the
first time you're hearing about it we're
talking about as it were in the way that
intelligence of old would you know Freud
have somebody's having an affair or they
got something embarrassing in their life
alcoholism or lack of money you're
saying that now is happening on a grand
state organized scale in order to try
and on
the mine the security of an adversary
yeah in industry sectors they're
interested in there's very clear
evidence happening there was a I'm doing
a debate at the Oxford Union tomorrow
night and they debate organizers put me
on the it's a privacy versus security
debate have we given up our privacy for
a false promise of security and they put
me on the privacy side although I'm a
security guy and the way I'm gonna
approach it is to say yes because we
have surrendered so much of our privacy
to the Internet available for data
intelligence miners for hackers for
everybody and it creates a security
issue but the additional component of
that now is that those on the internet
are so effective at mining information
about us not only your search history
your date preferences what you eat where
you travel but also how you think such
that you can be targeted for a
customized political appeal watch the 60
Minutes segment eight days ago of an
interview of the guy that ran digital
for Trump's campaign and they tailored
100 thousand different messages that
essentially said the same thing by you
know by my colors psychographics to
individual targeting individual voters
with micro targeting that's how
sophisticated this stuff is begun they
figured out according to this guy they
figured out that people who barbecue
outdoors are more likely to go for
Donald Trump so go find people who buy
outdoor grills and you know so I just
wanna break Jamie on this because
there's a very striking
but everything was part two of your
secret Silicon Valley in which you've
got one of these guys ended Trump's
media yeah to look into you yeah it
wasn't some of the did twenty was
someone they
invented the way to collect data to
build the psychographic modeling at the
Cambridge analytic are then used in the
Trump campaign in a way that you said it
kind of went beyond simply you bought X
therefore you might be interested in
Wyden which is I'm used to
we ham it up a bit on TV but you looked
as if you were genuinely shocked by
something they'd found out I was
absolutely staggered that based on some
likes that I'd put on Facebook they had
worked out that I was 40% likely to be
of no religion and 38% likely to be
Catholic I went to a well I went to a
Catholic school and and was raised as a
Catholic but I'm not I mean I'm sure you
can one of those Catholics yes I could
not believe in when you speak to the
people that build these models they say
they don't understand why either it's
about just pure numbers I mean it's
about trying to work out complicated
correlations between millions of likes
that different people have had and their
preferences and everyone that works in
this space says maybe it's not perfect
yet but this is the direction of travel
its own we're talking at the moment
about where we are now it's only gonna
get more and more sophisticated because
we're producing exponentially more data
about if you're at this you know basic
you what's coming so now biometrics are
coming more into this space you know and
there are some authentication companies
out there that actually literally
monitor your every keystroke it's not
just about your fingerprint your face
this is about monitoring your facial
responses we're going to have eye
tracking on devices in the next few
years right
so they don't just know which books you
bought but if you have them on your own
yet electronic device they're know
exactly whether you've read them or not
which bits you've read them which bits
you got excited about right and if you
look in the right in the commercial
space this is already exploited in terms
of very sophisticated targeting you know
to find the right time of day to give
you the rock which is irresistible right
something a very fundamental year when
it comes to politics and political
appeals what it means therefore is that
we're no longer communicating
this is who I am and this is what I
stand for vote for me we're figuring out
the most effective way to get inside
your head
so that what I show you is inclined it's
gonna make you inclined to vote for me
so we need a shrink for presidency we'll
see if thumbs and you before we open up
to the audience I want to just give you
a chance to talk about two things there
one you've just described the biometrics
so I when I knew I was going to
interview thought what she's gonna tell
me it's gonna be okay cuz it you know
nobody can do my iris that's gonna be
fine okay fingerprint that's not an
absolute it are you saying that you know
by matches maybe the answer in their
short-term to solve this problem of
having to put endless passwords in but
soon someone's aren't gonna know what my
iris looks like and soon they're gonna
know what my fingerprint looks like no
no what I was actually saying is well I
mean we've seen this is this is often a
question of how well is it exactly you
know how well half the people were
implementing the stuff done their
homework so so frankly you know I mean
if your major international and you
release an iris recognition system that
can be hacked in 24 hours then you just
didn't do it right but no I mean in a
way these these static biometrics like
fingerprint and that's yesterday that's
yesterday's tech today you know the
tomorrow's tech is behavioral so this is
like you know every if you've you know
do you know how many sensors your phone
has and all the kind of data that
actually leaks over the way you hold it
the way you tilt it the way you type the
speed at which you read all of that but
then Commission it's completely used to
secure us as well as for you've spelt
out very clearly about how it can be
used to attack us as it were either as
consumers or targets can it also be used
to secure yes and it is being used for
that in fact some banks in this country
already use this technology
you can't give us an example of not that
I didn't mean need to get you to think
about why D company I didn't I did what
behavior what sort of behavior is being
used by well it would start with with
with things like you know when you
typically do your banking but it would
actually literally look at how you miss
hit the keys
for instance on your soft and the soft
keyboard what they by definition is it
were not tell me that that's how they
would check it miss Garrity in other
words could they be using technology
about how I did and not tell me and this
is they don't want to alert people to
the phone's technology I've got it's I
said no no some customers some bank
customers who were very surprised when
they found out that their bank was using
this to journalist here just Gabor
that's a piece and then there are two
guys you know stuff you know stuff as
well Jamie and then when allows the
mailing really just ago which is why
because they know they really can ask
you all one last question before we open
up okay you raised and I think you did
as well answer the beginning this sense
that the trust in the web as a whole
trust in the internet could be
undermined do you get a sense that one
of the reasons there are cyber attacks
is a deliberate attempt to undermine
people's faith in using the Internet in
other words it is it is it also at all
because if people get used to being
frightened of it will hold us back
economically as a country may have other
impacts as well is there a deliberate
attempt to you last well around our
election there was a school of thought
in the intelligence community that what
the Russians were doing was a deliberate
attempt to undermine Americans
confidence in the election process
itself
not so much to force a certain outcome
but to just undermine the integrity of
the system generally on the assumption
that Hillary Clinton was gonna win
anyway
so in answer your question there was
definitely that school of thought last
year since the the perfect outcome for
them because I didn't think Trump could
win would be Hillary elected yes but
with people thinking it was corrupt or
you know that she shouldn't have war
know you had one candidate saying it was
gonna be rigged yeah it's quite right so
if it looked like it was rigged
we know benefits okay you raised the
point more generally about undermining
faith in the Internet yes and and I
agreed I think especially how success
all that seemed to have been other
countries are going to going to copy it
but mine was actually my thought about
it is that it's a more it's a more
organic and accidental process so just
by the logic of having a network
decentralized system which the internet
still is yes of course there's
centralized companies with lots of data
but the general logic of it is is
decentralized and it's cross-border
and so the inevitably that is going to
make it very difficult for governments
and law enforcement to be able to
enforce the law and he's not gonna get
better it's gonna get worse I would
suspect that there will be state actors
who are very happy to play on that to
undermine people's confidence in
democracy as you said but also in the
intelligence agencies in the police and
in a sense their kind of contract
between citizens and the state you know
there's there is already an enormous
amount to chew on to ponder to think
about and indeed to ask questions about
so I'm gonna open it up now and we'll
take have you got one here number one
have you got one there let's start just
there thank you very much if you
wouldn't mind certainly it's easier for
everybody thank you so much for being
here
all of you mr. Johnson thank you for
your service my question is regarding
the relationship between government and
business and so when there are issues of
cyber warfare or cyber security and
attacks like there have been with Apple
for example various court cases I'm
curious to know your what your thoughts
on whether it is the duty of Commerce to
protect its consumers or to not bow down
but to cooperate with the government on
a on a case by case basis there are some
success stories on the whole I have been
disappointed in the level of a
cooperation that exists for example
between the Department of Homeland
Security and the private sector so far
two years ago we created at Homeland
Security something called automated
information sharing for the private
sector so that they could give us cyber
threat indicators with lightning speed
and before we distributed it to anybody
else that goes to a privacy scrub and
unfortunately very few private sector
actors have taken advantage of that not
enough and what they seem to be doing
much more is sharing information
everyone benefits in the cybersecurity
world for the information sharing but
what the private sector seems to be
doing is sharing information through
these information sharing organizations
that are private and so I'd like to see
us do better when it comes to Congress
our Congress made an attempt in 2012 to
legislate certain minimum federal
standards and the private sector pushed
back on it and it got nowhere and so we
did get cyber legislation through our
Congress in 2015 which empowered my
department did a lot of other things but
no mandated federal standards because
many in the private sector would fight
that tooth and nail these review ones
are just coming on I mean in particular
it's been about access to phones that
are locked has been the issue but of
course there's also been the access to
messages that are covered by end-to-end
encryption we tend to think of what's
our but it's not the only people who do
it there is absolutely no way around
this problem I just don't think there's
an answer I mean on the one hand I do
not want there to be a single space
online where the authorities with lawful
warrants cannot access but to do that
they have to usually quite fundamentally
undermine the basics of encryption which
are also used in countries where there
aren't legal protections for citizens so
we have we are stuck there is no way
around this problem and I kinda like
crudely in other words if they do it for
you know the United States government
the federal government or indeed for the
UK then kiss goodbye to say that the
Egypt
skander Russians got no the Chinese got
there precisely and if they try to
undermine encryption standards which had
been discussed in the past but I don't
think really is anymore then that
undermines them for everybody and so
you're in this awful position where in
this country you might say we need to be
able to access the terrorists you know
messages but the cost of doing that is
going to be some poor journalists in
Russia who's gonna find himself going
you know round it up so it's a very very
difficult position to be in all the
computer scientists all the leading
computer scientists agree absolutely on
this if you're interested Google for a
paper called keys under doormats which
actually explains the solving data just
what it's a detail I know but it's been
in the news a lot so forgive me that's
why I'll ask you about it on whatsapp
it's always said for example this isn't
in fact complete end-to-end encryption
because they wanted to maintain the
technology that if you swap phones you
can move a message from one phone to the
other there's an opening there's a door
there and that's a door they could open
to the security services true well
you'll know so then the question is
should they J open that door well some
people believe that the only thing that
should be impenetrable is the human mind
and that if we can get a warrant to
lawfully require the disclosure of a
phone conversation or a diary or your
dresser drawer in your bedroom why not
an encrypted communication what's so
special about that some people believe
that and I agree with Jamie's assessment
we are where we are in response to the
demands of the marketplace and we've
gone down this road and it's very
difficult to walk it back lots of
questions and let's take one over just
so you know where I'm going to I'm going
to take the one here and the one at the
back and the one at the side here and
then we'll we'll start over
yep good evening I was just wondering
with the future of artificial
intelligence all that make wall that
remove
miscalculation emotion out of future
nation-state warfare what kind of
intelligence I'm sorry could you just
just if you because I suspect there's a
thought I know I said don't give a
speech but there's a thought underlying
the question how so how might it well is
it going to actually support the
attacker or the defender the move in
artificial intelligence as we go forward
thoughts anybody I could give a quick
answer I think it will support the
attacker because I think we we have the
arms race that we've talked about
already and Jay said at the beginning
that it's you know we're trying to catch
raindrops and there's just content and I
think with the continued advance of
artificial intelligence that is going to
make this even more difficult it is
essential to me that governments are the
ones in the end that are the leaders in
artificial intelligence and it is going
to have to be so highly regulated so
it's a very different world in a sense
that we're about to move into do you
think AI is regulatable if there is such
a verb is not I think I mean yeah the
last question I I have a different view
philosophically and technically and
maybe it's the case that it won't be
possible to regulate it in the same way
but I think that what I'm worried about
is that the greatest advances in
artificial intelligence in the end will
fall to private companies they will have
developed enormous power unprecedented
monopolies over a range of different
industries monopolies and inequality do
not work well with democracy it is
that's important so governments are
going to have to step in yep actually
one of my my colleagues and rod let's go
from the University of Minnesota
actually make makes he wrote a paper
about this and there's also a YouTube
video if here if you're interested and
he actually made the case that if this
power basically this knowledge lies in
the hand of of a small number
technical companies that's actually the
end of capitalism as we know it because
basically so you're using this
artificial intelligence the information
and the algorithms which is there to
profile people to such an extent that
you really don't have a choice and as a
consumer you don't really know the
market you spent this AI is another
intelligence squared hour just just
produced a final brief thought J when I
was in Silicon Valley recently you know
Elon Musk people will know is warming
endlessly about the risks of AI and the
fact that for example remote drones if
deployed by the US military could then
be used by any terrorist organization
biological organizations as well so that
there is remote military attacks I mean
is that sort of thing
strike as fanciful or does that strike
you as exactly what we should be worried
about well when I was general counsel of
the Department of Defense part of my job
was to give the legal sign off for a lot
of counterterrorism operations and you
know it's interesting
drones are kind of in the same space as
encryption you know in response to
demands in the marketplace you know
pretty soon we're gonna have drones
delivering your food to your house
surveillance you know there's some
really incredible drones that do all
kinds of surveillance and the technology
is available and it's not regulated so
the answer is the answer is yes we've we
face this issue the level of
sophistication and accuracy is widely
different obviously use of drones by the
by the United States government for
military purposes has increased the
accuracy has increased dramatically just
since you know in the last eight years
allowed you to get his office office
gear so we're going to try and get his
back well we back on sabe security of
the ballot if we look at China they have
the Great Firewall of China which who
sticks internet access in that country
and if we then look at Russia there are
limitations over the you
of encryption within the country so do
we see a scenario here where when we
talk about economic sanctions the the
Western states start to think about
cyber sanctions so the you know whilst
anybody can get through on the Internet
but at the same time we could actually
develop firewall technology that like
nation-state firewalls that effectively
put cyber limitations on other nation
states so the equivalence of economic
sanctions cyber sanctions my answer is
when you're dealing with conventional
state actors really the only way you're
ever gonna prevent this is to simply
make it cost prohibitive for that
conventional state actor that President
or that prime minister or that king or
whatever to engage in this behavior
because they know that the worse it'll
be cost-prohibitive
I just want coasts in the widest
possible sense maybe financial but maybe
but let's go over reputation whatever
but you have to make it cost prohibitive
yeah and that's what you but the idea of
of innocence saying look we want to
punish China for whatever reason there
we will limit their ability to access
our own Internet is practical is
thinkable is an interesting idea come
and work for a think tank yes well but
if you'll forgive me picking up I
thought from there I think for many
people there I I hope I speak for some
other people in the room when they hear
of the Great War Firewall of China they
think well hold on a thought you said it
wasn't really doable I thought you said
five years ago that you know the
Internet is an untamable space how come
they can do it then well because the
amount of resources and manpower that
they put into it and the cost that
they've I mean they've obviously decided
that it is worth the cost I mean
Facebook can't be accessed there but
actually there are a lot of activists in
China that do use the tor browser and do
get around the firewall and there are
all sorts of other workarounds you just
don't hear about very much what side of
the firewall we're gonna put Hong Kong
on good question good US commerce right
there very good question yeah
I'm from the London globalist it's a
student newspaper in the UK and my
question is basically they're sent it to
secretary Johnson a few years ago the
Lyndon Johnson library released audio
tapes that showed Richard Nixon having
colluded with the Vietnamese to sabotage
the 1968 peace treaty and in doing so
watching the Vietnam documentary aren't
you yeah Ken Burns very good yeah yeah
it's gonna relate to Donald Trump okay
so basically what isn't that you've got
quite a few decades to go through so no
I'll get quickly so and Richard Nixon
had done so violating the Logan Act to
win a presidential election now Donald
Trump's been accused of doing something
similar with the Russians so my question
is how different is and more importantly
how much more powerful is cyber
political intervention committed to
other political interventions that have
occurred since the beginning of
nation-states America's intervened in
almost every country in the world how is
this different and if it is different is
it more powerful thank you very much
everybody's looking at me okay so
whatever whatever history has shown the
United States or other countries have
done in the past does not mean we should
not do everything possible to protect
our own people from a cyberattack and as
I suspect you know there are a range of
things that the Independent Counsel is
investigating including collusion over
cybersecurity but also colluded he
appears to be investigating possible
occlusion in other respects of a more
traditional nature and potential
violations of the Logan Act I don't
think there's ever been a criminal
prosecution for violation of the Logan
Act by the way but the the Nixon Johnson
episode is pretty pretty graphic
Just Breathe l now I'm gay I'm breaking
my rule again
but how can you have him here and not
ask you how likely is it the President
Trump will be impeached well let me not
go there let me be serious for a moment
you know the longer he's in office the
more the American people are going to
get used to this kind of stuff you know
there was a there was a ruling of a
United States District Court last week
that our president harbored harbors a
religious animus that he has attempted
to translate into official government
policy never in my lifetime what I
thought that I would see a finding of my
own president engaging in such a thing I
would say spell it out for some you know
some days what was the story that led to
this the travel ban litigation yeah and
I would have said that it happens in
other countries can't happen in mind the
longer he's in office the more people
are going to get used to this kind of
thing and so people ask well when's he
gonna get impeached or when is the 25th
amendment gonna get invoked you have to
remember elections are not referendums
they're choices between two people and
so those who want to see change in my
country and elsewhere should not take
for granted that he won't survive for
terms or they won't get reelected that's
where we are 40 percent of the American
people approve of president Trump's
conduct in office it is a bit of a
difference I think there's an
unprecedented opportunity for ordinary
citizens of other countries to get
involved in elections because you can
now have hundreds of thousands of
Russian nationals or whoever online
trying to change opinion influence it in
one way or another I think in a way that
simply was not possible 20 or 30 years
ago and it's the same reason for this
democratization of
the tools of cyber cyber crime you know
you can now have somebody in Russia or
the Ukraine or wherever else where the
UK police has no jurisdiction whatsoever
committing a relatively low level but
quite profitable for them crime against
the UK citizen in this country and there
is not dancing the police can do about
that and it is the same in our elections
so when we talk about the Russians have
hacked our elections and we're going to
do something about that I struggled to
understand what that's going to be
because there's no way of stopping that
international flow of information now
well unless it is as Jay was saying
extracting a high enough price that that
state acts against its own citizens to
stop unordinary but on ordinary citizens
from those countries from those hostile
countries for example you can't really
do much about that there's two here so
if if you so that we don't only get the
outside edge converge into the middle in
the way our politics is not over there
Thanks
hello quick question is how do you see
besides privacy other impacts in
people's life are the cyber threats or
derived consequences of privacy issues
related to such threats or attacks what
are the biggest other threats well you
have foreign actors intervening in a
democracy meant for starters that's what
happened last year and it does present a
security issue so yep anybody else wants
to comment on that let me bring in
there's a question that hello yeah hi hi
so we've had or it's been proven that
there has been tampering in UK brexit
election alongside that of the tampering
that we saw in the US election for those
of us with a little knowledge it strikes
me that we seem far behind what our
adversary states seemed to be applying
there is
no Geneva Convention for this cyber war
and we seem to be far behind I think my
questions of the panel is what do we
need to see happen for us to recognize
that as a as a people or perhaps as
Western developed democracies before we
we change just be clear are you
referring to allegations and they are
only that at the moment that the
Russians had some involvement in the
brexit referendum I believe it has been
proven that much like in the American
election advertising social media
influence has been applied within brexit
when it comes to certain advertisements
and behaviors and certain targeting what
I'm familiar with is exists and there
was a lot of social media activity at
times at which certain parts of the
world were rather more awake than the
United Kingdom is the way it's been put
to me rather delicately Christian is
what do we do about it Jamie well I
think we're gonna suffer for a while I
think there will be the natural
mechanism by which individuals and
businesses start to understand the scale
of this threat and as you heard already
there's already an awful lot more work
that has gone into that so we are
beginning to try at least to push back
generally speaking my advice to
businesses on this is is actually to
assume that you have been hacked your
stuff is going to be stolen your secrets
are going to be stolen and what you need
to do is have a good backup plan ready
so it's about being prepared in the
event of this rather than trying to
avoid any one more final thing just a
quick mindset may be about for example I
see a lot of stories of young people in
school brilliant at computer programming
they get in trouble for hacking into
their school database because they're
just so curious about it we got to
cultivate those people these guys are
the ones that are gonna help us we've
got to have a bit of a mindset change
about the young people that are
brilliant at hacking into things because
in the end they're the best people to
know how to fix it Nepal's there and I
don't know where that's because the
person who is reporting is a hacker
if you are a hacker please come and
identify yourself afters Oh or teach it
we're gonna take number one in the mid
twos think called ethical hacking that a
lot of businesses and government
agencies use where you've got people in
a windowless room that spend all day
long
trying to hack into your own system with
your own with your consent attrition
testing is code and it's amazing I think
the answer isn't just in technology you
know I think we've allowed in the way
technology to really take up far too
much of our of our air time and face
time and and become you know too much of
an intermediary in our conversations and
the way we relate to each other you know
and I always say it's like one of the
fundamental things to understand about
privacy is that it's about relationships
right and our ability to actually manage
relationships and I think this this kind
of know when we see these kind of golf's
you know which are now being exploited
of people you know really having
completely irrelevant reviews that is
because we haven't been in a way forced
to have those conversations with each
other face to face and and this
basically creates this divergence and
this echo chamber where people just
repeat their favorite you know their
favorite views to each other and
nobody's is really really forced to have
that conversation and to pull back and
to actually dig out the facts and really
find out what the answer is and I should
think we should go back to actually
having more debates face to face and and
looking at facts what we have to relearn
this rather than believe everything it's
a very good advert for intelligence
squared says here we are face to face
very traditional town-hall meeting as
well as seeing it online of course
let's take number one and number two
what I'm going to do in a second is get
you to have some wind-up thoughts and if
you'd like me to later but I have a
funny sense you will and Angela
particularly I hope will forgive me for
doing this you can if it's one minute a
very practical advice about what all the
people in this room should do if they
want to avoid being a hat because I
suspect there's a lot of it is it
anybody want that yeah better else so
we'll do that yeah number one number two
good evening thank you very much for
this very interesting talk I have a very
simple question why
is cybersecurity so difficult
should we do another hour why it's
actually there is a simple answer to
this which is that at the moment there
is no commercial incentive on people who
create new technology and new services
to think security from the outset and
it's it's so the people who create it
just think about functionality and the
wonderful new business and then they
start thinking you know only when the
attacks happen and all the security it's
like bits of sticky plaster stuck on and
that's why it's complicated and
cumbersome so a catchphrase and just
turning well this is I think it is and
particularly when we speak to older -
older consumers and older citizens who
actually said you know I don't want a
new phone every couple of years I want
something that that that works you know
and I want something that's solid and
proven I think a lot a lot more
consumers will start to look at those
things and I've heard those
conversations in department stores you
know show you about that TV that me oh
no no that's got the audio thing so
we'll some some listen to our
conversation we'll GCHQ listen to what
we talk about in front of like no no I
don't want to voice control TV you hear
those conversations and I think but some
technologists people are so really until
zombies Georgie becomes a selling point
yes there's not the financial incentives
yeah I think and that can be both for
devices but also for the services here
being offered right the contract is that
your your telco or your various service
providers actually offer you certain
guarantees and certain protections
sergej if I could more and more CEOs of
businesses are forcing themselves to
understand cybersecurity better than
they do what what CEOs and cabinet
secretaries used to do you get an email
about cybersecurity oh I'm forwarding
this to my chief information officer I
can't think about this and I don't
understand it and now you see cyber
attacks can go to the very survival of a
business like Equifax or or what the
North Koreans did to Sony a couple of
years ago goes to the very survival of
their business and so they're starting
to pay attention
that was definitely true in the cabinet
in the Obama administration I'd send my
colleagues email after email after email
that I know they were forwarding to
their chief information officers but
then finally the message came to the
White House you are legally responsible
for your own system and so I think I
feel as though it's moving in the right
direction
number two him my own oh yeah Angela's
responsive asked question makes me want
to ask do you think passwords are
obsolete and making security easy for
people but that's not my question ma'am
I want to talk about a cutting crime
like monitoring communications to kind
of detect terroristic activity or
whatever and something that Jamie and
Jays been talking about a lot and the
argument that so governments tend to ask
Oh give us like all your data or give us
they get a warrant that's like
overbearing and then they say and then
we'll sort out what's interesting right
and you were talking earlier about
getting cooperation from companies like
Google or whoever who have the data
themselves to try and filter out and
find themselves I think that's something
I'm much more interesting because what's
the question
the question is the question is because
that seems to be safer for people
because there isn't locus censorship how
does that work can the government say to
the company this is what we want you to
look for can you filter on that can you
look for that could be a lot narrower
search would that be a way of persuading
corporates to cooperate is can
government depend upon the private actor
to do the filtering themselves that your
question yeah and that can they be
specific about what they're looking for
so first can they filter and second
could they also rely on the private
actor to do it that that I believe that
that happens on a case-by-case basis as
opposed to a warrant give me every
message generated in a five year period
from anybody on the planet to anybody
else on the planet
I believe that kind of thing does happen
because it it has to happen just to get
the job done
yeah the tech firms have definitely
started to take that responsibility a
lot more seriously I think for me
governments though they will always try
to get as much data as they
because they will have a tendency to say
we don't know in advance what we'll need
we can't be very precise we'd like to
capture as much as possible it's called
bulk access and then under warrant we
will filter it ourselves and look at it
and you can trust us we won't look at
anything else I get why they do that but
that only works if everybody trusts the
oversight system and the regulatory
system that governs all of that I don't
think they do funny enough actually this
is a point where science and common
sense conquer so far in the studies that
have been done it's very clear that you
don't make the needle easier to find by
making the haystack bigger now we
discuss it sounds like and philosophical
Confucius he say will help to do that
actually we're almost out of time so
forgive me ladies general we've got the
hands up now if you haven't got a
microphone in front of you I'm afraid
we're out of time we're gonna take two
in a row and see if they're related and
then we're gonna get some wind-up
thoughts yes over there and then over
there and I'm sorry that were then a dot
on you you talked at the start about
attacks on critical national
infrastructure and industrial control
systems controlling energy grids and
suchlike
but I'm wondering what it's that extent
you think the United States opened
Pandora's box so to speak with the
Stuxnet worm which targeted the Iranian
nuclear program and was perhaps the
first attack of its kind and such
infrastructure Angela you smiled
probably direct I'm not sure how to
answer it I'm not sure I'd answer it
sorry I spent the question which I don't
think takes your place you don't want to
go is it is like if you do it to someone
else on they bound to do it to you is it
was that broadly a point I think so yeah
well yeah yep okay okay thank you very
much my question is a partly based on a
conversation many years ago with a
supposedly former member of the GRU who
was teasing me with his comments which
were basically why is it taken the West
so long to catch up with this one and to
which my answer was yeah I wish I knew
as well
my question is attribution are there any
comments you have regarding attribution
where you're positively you're surprised
it's been pretty good in attributing or
where you're concerned and disappointed
thank you attribution very often when
you're talking about attribution to a
nation-state actor of bad cyber behavior
very often it's relatively easy to
figure out the signature the
fingerprints of the bad actor and the
real issue is who's pulling the strings
and after or around the time of North
Korea we developed in the US government
a criteria policy criteria for when we
make attribution the election episode
last year in my judgment was very
different you don't go through the
normal considerations without
attribution because there was an
independent overriding need during the
election to tell the voters and the
public what we knew was going on in
their election so that they are informed
it would have been unforgivable in my
opinion to not tell the public what we
knew and what we saw going on probably
there was another thing going on in your
mind before you agreed to do that which
is you might do the Russians job fool
them as it where you might actually
undermine faith in the democratic
process there is that there was that
school
yes and I and others and ultimately the
president concluded better to have
informed voters better they know better
they know even when it came to K me
later on better they know you know I can
tell why was director of Homeland
Security this is a very careful about
what he said can I bring you to some
closing remarks and now Jonah forgive me
I'll finish with you
Angela's going to kick off if that's all
right no I tell you what I think there
was quite a warm you know words of
approval after the idea some very
practical for people here are thinking
and it may be just go read this what
would you say to people here worrying
about cybersecurity in their own lives
or in their own businesses lives so
number one is it's one of the big a lot
of you will have heard about one of the
big waves at the moment is ransomware
and actually that affects individuals
but also it affects companies and we've
seen money extorted up to like a million
dollars and I think that will just go up
so so there's just a lot of very
confusing and bad advice out there so my
number one advice would be is anything
you care about make sure you have a
clean backup all right
so so make it and you know just get
yourself a very big USB stick or a drive
and make sure you have a clean copy
because then nobody can extort money
from you if you you know if you have a
copy of it if you're really concerned
about your tater number to learn how to
encrypt it there are some products out
there number three with the passwords
it's not the strength of the password
that matters what matters is that you
don't reuse important passwords across
so it's basically for your banking for
your main work account your main email
account take the effort of having a
unique password it's okay to write it
down if you keep it in a you know if you
keep it on you and secured and for
everything else use a password manager
or something else
those would be my top three tips and
then number four is yes I know those
updates are annoying and I wish they
could actually get a bit more organized
that we'd only maybe have to do it once
a month but the updates also most of
them are security relevant updates so
keep to your phones and your yes I can
actually keep my passwords in a row in a
Russian dole ironically Russian Russian
doll in my bedroom because we used to
use those things we called them address
books is the most secure way if you just
give us your address that we can get the
whole lot so just there I think this is
going like we mentioned before this is
going to get worse before it gets better
the Internet of Things the so-called
Internet enabled devices that we haven't
really talked about of which they're
supposedly going to be twenty billion by
2020 has already been exposed as having
pretty bad basic security flaws so all
the things that we are already worried
about will get worse but there is good
news in things getting bad in the case
of ransomware for example suddenly
everyone is way more concerned about
clicking on things they didn't know they
fit a bit but a year ago or two years
ago I think anyone had heard of
ransomware and the NHS thing I mean
actually was probably worth more to GCHQ
and the people concerned with
cybersecurity than any amount of
advertising they could have done so we
will respond as a society there's no
doubt about that
the role for government I think is often
to incentivize and encourage that
because there are simple things we can
do but in the end I can't stress enough
governments are going to have to do more
we could talk about education and it's
wonderful and but governments are going
to have to do more and they're gonna
have to take more responsibility on this
which means we're gonna have to regulate
that power more so we've got some
difficult conversations ahead and is
that your message phone DJ that this is
something that now must not be sent to
the information officers this has to be
the center of political debate and the
debate about the rights of citizens
versus the right equation I used to end
many of my public speeches when I was
secretary by saying I can build you a
perfectly safe city but it would be a
prison and you don't want it and I could
build you a perfectly safe commercial
air flight
but you'd never take it because you
wouldn't be wearing any clothes you
wouldn't be allowed to get up from your
seat you wouldn't be allowed to eat
wouldn't have any check luggage and I
could build you a perfectly safe
cyber safe Internet system but it would
be a conversation with ten people inside
a wall with no access to the Internet
and that's not what the public wants in
a free and democratic society in this
context and we have gone so far down the
road of surrendering our privacy in ways
that I don't think the public at large
fully understands they do in some level
but not fully you know when I was a kid
it was super sensitive what books I
checked out of the library
and now you know collectively actors on
the Internet can know everything about
you and act on it and exploit it to some
degree and it's going to be very
difficult if not impossible to pull back
from that because we're marching
mightily and fast in the opposite
direction with the Internet of Things
and other things well I hope you agree
ladies gentleman has been absolutely
fascinating I want to think on your
behalf not just intelligence squared for
staging this event but of course to
thank jeh Johnson to thank Jamie
Bartlett and Angela sass thank you very
much indeed
you